JAMES NORRIS: My
name's James Norris,
and I'm the founder
and CEO of DeadSocial.
DeadSocial is the
end-of-life planning tool.
This enables us to say goodbye
to our friends and family,
both on and offline.
Today I'm going to show
you the six-step process
that I follow to ensure that
my business and brand utilizes
pop-up spaces and event spaces
to the best of our ability.
So the first step,
you really have
got to look at
deciding when, where,
and how you're going to run
your event or pop-up shop.
So the first thing
you may want to do
is try to justify
the amount of time
and spend that you're
going to dedicate
on a specific project-- so if
you're running an exhibition
space, the cost of the
stand, the amount of resource
that you're going to need to
allocate, et cetera, et cetera.
By running our
pop-up shop, we have
managed to forge a
number of very, very
strong relationships,
both within the profit
and the not-for-profit sector.
This has led to
business being attained.
And it has also led to
an increased awareness
of our brand within the sector.
We launched DeadSocial last
year at South by Southwest,
and we wanted to create
as much noise as possible.
South by Southwest is the
biggest tech conference
in the world, so we had to
create a strong narrative that
engaged with both the general
public and the tech community
at large.
We decided to hire a small venue
called The Museum of the Weird
to help evoke discussion and
thought prior to the event.
We sold our launch
party out by tenfold,
and the event had a
strong creative narrative
running through it.
At each event, we try to drive
a story or a different narrative
to help to ensure
that it's fresh
and to help ensure
that it engages
with the general public.
During Dying Matters
Awareness Week,
we created, for example,
a live infographic.
The way the live
infographic worked
was we took a near
real-time data
feed from the
digital death survey,
and during the
course of the week as
and when the data was
populated, we populated
and we updated the physical
installation in space
to help reflect the data
that was being generated.
Both South by Southwest and the
pop-up shop that we carried out
for Dying Matters Awareness
Week were very different.
In terms of their
narrative, they
both took a very,
very different path.
However, they both helped
reflect the brand image
and helped to evoke
discussion around our business
and our core ethos.
At the Ideal Death Show, we
had a small exhibition stand.
So it's very, very different
to the pop-up space.
But again, we wanted
to create a narrative
and tell a story around
technology and around death.
We decided to use a DSLR
camera and very simply just
to increase the shutter speed.
By doing so, we emulated
the Victorian photos
and the Victorian
ghost images that
are very intertwined with
Victorian mythology and to try
and highlight that relationship
between both technology
and death.
Step 6-- Reviewing and
Gauging Success Metrics.
There are a number
of ways in which you
can analyze and review your own
success at an event or whilst
carrying out a pop-up shop.
These range from a quantitative
statistical-based analysis
based on your Google analytics,
the amount of shares,
the amount of tweets,
et cetera, all the way
through to that
general gut feeling
or the value that you place on a
partnership that's been forged.
I have followed the
six steps to help
ensure that my brand creates as
much noise as possible whilst
at events and
running pop-up shops.